[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue avant de
démarrer je voulais vous remercier pour
l'accueil très chaleureux que vous avez
réservé à la précédente vidéo sur les
peuples de la mer visiblement ces
thématiques purement archéologiques vous
plaisent énormément et ça tombe bien
parce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai prévu de vous
parler d'un site archéologique bien
précis l'abri ban ki moon
cette vidéo est en partenariat avec
ecoscience provence alpes côte d'azur
avec qui j'avais déjà travaillé il ya
deux ans sur la grotte cosquer et je
vous mets le lien de la vidéo dans le
petit est un on a décidé de remettre le
couvert en même temps à parler vaisselle
poterie en tant que cette expression bas
de soie plus sérieusement cette
collaboration est une occasion rare pour
échanger avec l'archéologue en charge de
ce site dit des bains d'air qui est
directeur de recherche émérite au cnrs
est rattaché au laboratoire ces pannes à
nice didier ben deja pas d'idée ou
binder comme je lé longtemps pensé car
après cette vidéo et pour poursuivre la
réflexion
une autre vidéo entretien vous attend
le néolithique est une invention
proche-orientale il est environ 12000
ans à la faveur de meilleures conditions
climatiques le nouvelles dispositions
sociale et symbolique des populations
ont commencé à se sédentariser et à
domestiquer des espèces végétales et
animales
l'europe reçoit cette innovation par
diffusion les techniques et modes de vie
élaborée entre la syrie et l'irak la
turquie actuelle sont apportées sur
notre continent a porté dans les bagages
des populations du moyen-orient qui ont
migré vers l'ouest la néolithisation le
processus par lequel l'europe voit
disparaître la chasse et la cueillette
au profit de l'agriculture et de
l'élevage est la conséquence d'un afflux
populations nouvelles
on observe au néolithique ancien la
phase la plus précoce de ce
bouleversement deux courants de
diffusion à travers le continent
l'un d'entre eux remontent le fleuve
danube et ses affluents au centre du
continent
l'autre empruntent les côtes
méditerranéennes au sud
chacun de ces courants a ses propres
spécificités culturelles sa manière de
faire des maisons des poteries et ses
plantes cultivées favorite et les
pionniers les emportent avec eux
toujours plus loin vers l'ouest
c'est ce que l'on nomme le package
néolithique un ensemble de traits
culturels propres à ce nouveau mode de
vie et qui en constitue la base la
trouvaille des éléments de ce package
néolithique hache polie poterie animaux
domestiques etc permet donc de retracer
la progression des premiers agriculteurs
à travers le continent
et autant le courant danubien avec ses
maisons longue et sa poterie à décor
rubané présente une progression quasi
continu et homogène autant le courant
méditerranéen montre un visage plus
complexe cette migration vers oued mer
traversant les baies et contournant les
péninsules ressemble plus à l'errance du
lit ce cas une croisière de retraités
les sites archéologiques connu qui
atteste du premier néolithique de
méditerranée sont éloignées de plusieurs
dizaines voire de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres et les fameux package qui
apportent les migrants présente de
fortes disparités
[Musique]
labrie peine 10 moon est une étape sur
cette route c'est comme son nom
l'indiqué un abri sous roche située dans
un relief calcaire de la commune de
castellar dans les alpes-maritimes
il trône à 690 mètres d'altitude 4 km au
nord de la ville de menton sa
localisation à l'extrême sud est de la
france constituent logiquement un point
d'entrée pour le néolithique
méditerranéen en provenance d'italie
c'est donc pour nous un site capitale
pour appréhender la néolithisation du
territoire les premières fouilles ont eu
lieu dans l'abri en 1955 avec une
méthode un peu radical une tranchée de
15 mètres de long est creusé en plein
milieu du site
cela a eu le mérite de montrer des
résultats rapides et de révéler tout le
potentiel du site mais cela a aussi
compliqué la tâche des archéologues
suivant cette tranche et empêchent
notamment de suivre les niveaux
d'occupation sur toute la surface de la
bri et d'être parfaitement sûr de la
correspondance des couches de sédiments
de part et d'autre je m'explique un site
archéologique et la plupart du temps
constitué de différentes strates de
sédiments qui se sont déposées les unes
sur les autres
on trouve donc une succession des tâches
qui vont du plus ancien en bas au plus
récent en eau ce principe très simple à
comprendre se nomme la stratigraphie
c'est la manière dont les archéologues
visualise le temps qui passe la fouille
d'un site archéologique
ça consiste en fait surtout à identifier
les différentes strates auxquels on a
affaire à peine dimoune l'érosion de la
falaise à apporter dans l'abri de
nouveaux sédiments de manière constante
ce qui a permis de sceller les niveaux
d'occupation humaine et de conserver
deux précieux vestiges mais la tranchée
coupant le site en deux a pas mal
compliqué la lisibilité de l'ensemble
toutefois l'ancienneté du site vaut bien
qu'on essaye de relever le défi de
nouvelles fouilles ont donc eu lieu à
partir de 1985 sous la direction de
didier 20 heures cette fois ci elles
adoptent des méthodes beaucoup plus
rigoureuse cela va sans dire les
archéologues en plusieurs années de
fouilles dans l'abri identifie notamment
un ensemble de couches stratigraphique
qui comporte des vestiges du néolithique
ancien en abondance
parmi ces vestiges la céramique à tirent
particulièrement leur attention les
différentes phases du néolithique ancien
militaire année 1 se reconnaissent en
effet grâce aux motifs qui ornent les
poteries ces objets utilisés
quotidiennement pour le stockage le
paysage de l'eau ou la cuisson sont
décorées durant la première étape du
néolithique par des impressions avec les
ongles une petite baguette un coquillage
ou simplement en pinçant l'argile
fraîche avec les doigts les potiers
mettait en relief leur production les
motifs sont la plupart du temps agencés
en bande sinueuses ou en plus grands
aplats envahissent la panse des poteries
une deuxième étape du néolithique de
méditerranée centrale et occidentale
voit l'utilisation massive de
coquillages dans la famille du quart
dionne pour imprimer des vaguelettes sur
l'argile en apposant le bord de la
coquille dans tes sur le vase avant
cuisson les artisans pouvait facilement
des corps et les céramiques ce procédé
qu'il supplante à cette époque les
autres styles de décor dans une large
région du bassin méditerranéen a valeur
de signes distinctifs pour les
archéologues
c'est pour cette raison que la première
étape du néolithique de méditerranée
centrale et occidentale est nommé in
pressent pour ses décors d'impression
est l'étape suivante guardian en
référence aux cards yom ces deux styles
sont assez fascinant différenciables car
il s'oppose en de nombreux points sans
des récipients technique et structures
du décor moyen de suspension et de
préhension au début de son équipe à sion
ban ki-moon fournit une céramique
original en effet les décors céramique
après ça sans équivalent régionale
proche notamment par son décor peint
c'est la rapproche davantage des styles
anciens du sud de l'italie notamment de
calabre voir des balkans plutôt que des
sites voisins du nord de l'italie ou du
sud de la france l'hypothèse privilégiée
lors des premières années et est donc
d'imaginer la grippe andy goode comme
une sorte de site pionnier une tête de
pont de la néolithisation en provenance
directe de l'italie du sud
un témoin privilégié de migration
longues distances sans escale dans le
reste de la péninsule italienne
les sites voisins comme celui des arènes
candide près de savone qui présente des
poteries décorée de façon très
différente
portrait la signature de groupes
pionniers d'origine
différentes un modèle séduisant
[Musique]
mais cette théorie qui met en avant une
forte diversité culturelle des premiers
colons néolithique est aujourd'hui
obsolète
l'analyse technologique des productions
céramiques réalisées dans un premier
temps à partir de l'observation des
traces visibles de façonnage a révélé
une surprise en 2017 et publié un
article montrant que les poteries de
plenty moon ne sont pas fabriqués par
collage de boudin d'argile horizontaux
comme partout dans l'europe néolithique
mais par l'utilisation de patch spiralé
cette première analyse a été confrontée
ensuite à une nouvelle technique
d'investigation
la tomographie cette méthode qui
consiste à exposer les tessons de
céramique à des rayons x permet
d'analyser leur structure interne est
ainsi de déterminer la technique
employée pour la fabrication des pots
même sur des vestiges en mauvais état et
à la conclu au même résultat
le tour de potier n'existe pas encore à
cette époque les artisans de penjwin
confectionner des petits rubans d'argile
qu'ils ont roulé sur eux-mêmes pour
former des spirales puis assemblés les
spirales d'entre elles pour former leurs
vases alors dit comme ça ça n'a pas
forcément l'air d'une information
incroyable mais en réalité pour les
préhistoriens c'est une petite
révolution pour comprendre ça il faut
expliquer le concept de chaîne
opératoire
une chaîne opératoire c'est une série
d'étapes qui forment ensemble une
technique et étudier une chaîne
opératoire c'est s'intéresser aux
méthodes de fabrication d'utilisation et
même d'abandon des objets ce concept
forgé par le préhistorien andré
leroi-gourhan puis repris par andré
georges haudricourt a été diffusé en
sciences humaines par andré nan
j'déconne
jacques tixier notamment il est utilisé
le plus souvent en préhistoire pour
l'analyse de l'industrie lithique c'est
à dire de la taille du silex
mais il s'applique en réalité à toutes
les techniques
c'est un concept clé pour la
compréhension des sociétés humaines par
l'intermédiaire de leur technique
en effet toutes les techniques nécessite
un apprentissage et se transmettent donc
entre artisans et en étudiant la
technologie on peut dégager des
filiations des traditions technique et
la proche par la chaîne opératoire
permet d'appréhender les mécanismes de
penser à l'oeuvre chez les artisans aux
différentes étapes de la chaîne
cela suppose en archéologie d'observer
le plus de traces possibles pour
reconstituer les gestes à chaque moment
de la vie d'objets le silex est un
matériau particulièrement propice à ce
genre d'observation puisqu'il enregistre
sur sa surface à la manière d'un disque
vinyle toutes les traces d'usure ou de
choc
il a pour cette raison été au coeur de
la création de la chaîne opératoire
mais ici le procédé est appliquée à la
céramique à peine dimoune l'observation
des traces sur les tessons puis dans
l'épaisseur par tomographie a donc
révélé la technique de montage céramique
par patch spirale et à tester sur tout
les poteries du site
elle marque une rupture dans la
technologie du néolithique ancien tel du
moon et le premier site sur lequel cette
technique est identifié par l'équipe de
louise gomart
[Musique]
l'analyse des trois autres sites
italiens permet ensuite de mieux
comprendre le phénomène
deux d'entre eux riz pâtes état en
italie du sud est est collé santostefano
en italie centrale ont montré un montage
classique des céramiques en boudin
horizontaux mais le site ligure des
arènes candide proche de penny moon
révèle le même procédé en spirale et
depuis beaucoup d'autres analyses ont
été menées
l'utilisation de la technique spirale
est attestée dans de nombreux autres
sites et dessine clairement une
frontière technique coupant l'italie en
deux entre le bassin adriatique à l'est
et le bassin tirrenia à l'ouest
étrange car les schémas opératoire les
maillons de la chaîne ne varie pas
facilement ils se transmettent le plus
souvent sans varier pendant des siècles
cela est bien attestée pour le
néolithique d'europe centrale il ya donc
fort à parier qu'on est bien là avec nos
spirale une culture différente et pas
une simple mutation locales les
mutations techniques se font plutôt
graduellement et par ajout de petits
éléments en commettant des erreurs puis
en se perfectionnant il paraît
impossible de voir apparaître une toute
nouvelle technique en quelques années on
n'est pas passés du minitel au
smartphone en six mois voyez cette
découverte suppose en fin de compte la
coexistence d'au moins deux groupes
distincts agissant dans le cadre de la
néolithisation du nord ouest de la
méditerranée au 59e siècle avant notre
ère 59e siècle je vous laisse faire le
calcul en commentaire labrie peine
dimoune considéré pendant un temps sur
la base du décor céramique comme sans
lien avec les sites voisins se trouve
donc être en réalité tout à fait
intégrés dans une culture cohérente du
néolithique ancien une culture
différente de celle qui anéantit zay
l'adriatique en provenance des balkans
reste à savoir d'où ils viennent qui a
inventé le coup de la spirale d'argile
quand et où
des études de paléogénétique ont
récemment montré que les squelettes
trouvés à peine dimoune porte un
pourcentage important de gênes typique
les populations de chasseurs cueilleurs
européen ceux qui étaient présents avant
l'arrivée des agriculteurs les
agriculteurs pionniers se sont donc à
peine 10 mois un peu plus mêlés aux
populations locales qu'ailleurs de là à
en conclure que la spirale et la
signature d'un métissage génétique et
culturels difficile à dire mais
l'hypothèse est séduisante
la clé de cette énigme l'origine
inconnue d'un deuxième courant de
néolithisation méditerranéen se trouve
encore quelque part sous la terre c'est
la fin de cet épisode merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé si vous avez question
utilisez commentaires mais surtout
surtout regardé l'entretien qu'on vous a
préparé c'est un entretien qui a été
filmé la semaine dernière dans lequel
didier bin der répond à mes questions
on a band plein de sujets qu'on pas pu
être abordés dans cette vidéo vous vous
en doutez ici on a essayé de vraiment
centré sur les dernières recherches qui
portait sur la céramique est donc dans
l'entretien on revient sur la question
du métissage aussi sur les sépultures ce
site ban ki moon a livré beaucoup de
sépulture notamment des avec des
squelettes qui marque qui porte par dont
la trace de deux coups il ya pas mal de
pathologies donc c'est très intéressant
ça reflète un petit peu les différents
statuts sociaux
voilà donc cliquer sur cet entretien
il est sur la chaîne des consciences
mais surtout liste est là dans le petit
é
dans la barre d'infos est épinglé en
commentaire avant de se quitter je
remercie l'uqat à corte à l'écriture et
lilian beuzelin stagiaires ce mois ci
sur la chaîne à la prochaine salut
[Musique]